bienvenido a mi presentación de sumando
y restando fracciones empecemos a
imagínate que yo tengo un cuarto
más un cuarto vamos a empezar con algo
sencillo tengo un cuarto más un cuarto
cuarto sexto
bueno pues imagínate que tenemos un
pastel aquí está mi pastel favorito me
gustan los pasteles ok y este pastel lo
voy a dividir en cuatro lo voy a dividir
en cuatro ok
dividamos lo algo así y lo pueden
dividir en cuatro ok
aquí está mi pastel favorito en cuatro
partes iguales ahora si yo digo que este
cuarto este primer cuarto es esta parte
del pastel y después tengo otra cuarta
parte del pastel esta otra cuarta parte
del pastel es esta otra cuarta parte del
pastel entonces cuanto es un cuarto más
un cuarto y lo gigante que yo lo como un
cuarto el pastel y después lo como otro
cuarto de pastel pues en total cuántas
partes del pastel me comí podemos
concluir que esto es lo mismo que dos
cuartas partes
me comí dos pedazos de este pastel pero
cada uno de los pedazos de este pastel
era una cuarta parte de este pastel es
decir que en total me comí dos cuartas
partes de este riquísimo pastel que por
cierto si te das cuenta esto es lo mismo
que la mitad del pastel realmente lo que
hice fue comerme dos cuartos del pastel
que es lo mismo que la mitad de este
pastel dónde ahora seguramente tú te
estás preguntando qué pasó aquí y lo que
quiero que veas y lo importante de este
ejercicio es que notes que este 4 y este
4 son iguales esta parte de abajo de una
fracción se llama denominador y en este
caso el denominador era el mismo el
denominador es 4 por lo tanto cuando
tengo dos fracciones con el mismo
denominador el denominador se conserva
fíjate que aquí llegamos a una fracción
con el mismo denominador el denominador
es 4 y lo único que hice fue tomarme la
suma de estos dos de arriba
massú no es lo mismo que dos de aquí
llegué a este dos o que el perfecto y
después lo que hice fue simplificar un
poco la fracción me di cuenta que
realmente comerme en dos cuartas partes
de un pastel es comerse la mitad del
pastel ok y de la misma manera podemos
pensar la siguiente suma de fracciones
si yo agarro y digo me voy a tomar 2
sobre 5 + 1 sobre 5 ok
dos quintos más un quinto cuántos esto
bueno pues podemos pensar en el pastel
dividido en cinco partes iguales pero
para no dibujarlo todo tenemos que
fijarnos en el denominador y como aquí
mi denominador sigue siendo el mismo
pues esto es lo mismo que poner el
denominador acá abajo y tomarme dos más
uno dos más uno lo cual por cierto
tres quintos me sigo tomando realmente
el pastel partido en la misma cantidad
de pedazos en la misma cantidad de
pedazos que son cinco y sirve
exactamente igual para la resta ya le
hicimos si por ejemplo yo tengo tres
sobre 73 séptimos ya esto le voy a
quitar un séptimo que crees la resta de
estos dos es lo mismo que mi denominador
es común por lo tanto lo voy a poner
siete y tres menos uno me daría 23 menos
1 me daría dos y el resultado serían dos
séptimos que por cierto no olvides y eso
sí es muy importante que este de aquí es
el denominador denominador de esta
fracción denominador
mientras que el de arriba el de arriba
se llama numerador
ya tengo mi denominador mi numerador
tengo un denominador común y ahora si
pongo el denominador común y me tomo la
suma y la resta de las cantidades que
tenga yo aquí arriba pero esto está muy
fácil cuando tenemos un denominador
común si te das cuenta ni siquiera
tuvimos que dibujar más pasteles pero
qué pasa si no tenemos el mismo
denominador y para eso dejarlo borrar el
pizarrón y vamos a pensar en fracciones
que no tengan el mismo denominador ok
ahora veamos otro ejemplo que sea
sencillo vamos a tomarnos el cuarto ok
ya esto le quiero sumar un medio y bueno
como a mí me gustan mucho los pasteles
vamos a seguir pensando en pasteles así
que qué te parece si dibujamos aquí a mi
pastel a base los pastel naranja no
tengo por aquí y aquí tengo a mi pastel
y ahora vamos a dividirlo en cuatro
partes primero lo voy a dividir aquí
algo así y después lo voy a dividir por
acá algo por acá ok
qué te parece si en primer lugar nos
tomamos un cuarto de este pastel en
primer lugar me voy
y un cuarto de este pastel y si te das
cuenta un cuarto es exactamente lo mismo
que esto estás de acuerdo
este sería un cuarto de pastel ahora
imagínate que después a esto le quiero
sumar un medio de pastel un medio de
pastel entonces si los comemos la mitad
del pastel realmente os tenemos comiendo
todo esto de aquí está de acuerdo y
bueno cuánto es un medio más un cuarto
lo que quiero que veas es que esté un
medio es exactamente lo mismo que
comerse esta parte del pastel que cuando
nosotros la dividimos en cuartos es lo
mismo que un cuarto este de aquí eso en
cuanto más otro cuarto estar acá es otro
parto o dicho de otra manera estoy
diciendo a lo voy a apuntar aquí que un
medio es lo mismo que dos cuartos que
dos cuartos dos pedazos de un cuarto de
este pastel o de esta pizza no se quería
tengo hambre y si un medio es lo mismo
que dos cuartos entonces esta fracción
no la podría escribir como
un cuarto déjame ponerlo con el mismo
color un cuarto un cuarto ya esto le voy
a sumar a un medio pero un medio no
podemos ver como dos cuartos como dos
cuartos y en este momento qué creés
pasamos de tener un denominador que no
era común aquí tengo un denominador de 4
mientras que aquí tengo un denominador
de 2 a una suma de fracciones que tienen
ahora un denominador común un cuarto
tiene un denominador de 42 cuartos tiene
un denominador de 4 y por lo tanto ahora
sí puedo decir que un cuarto más dos
cuartos es lo mismo que uno más 2
a cuartos que es lo mismo que tres
cuartos y es lo que se ve en este pastel
si te das cuenta lo único que no tomamos
fue esta parte de aquí pero realmente en
total nos tomamos esta parte de aquí y
todo esto nos comimos todo esto de acá
todo todo todo todo todo esto y nos
quedamos con esta parte es decir que
todo esto fue lo que nos comimos en
nuestro resultado total tres cuartas
partes de este pastel por lo tanto un
cuarto más un medio es lo mismo que tres
cuartos seguramente en este momento
estás pensando que hice magia como pase
de un medio a dos cuartos no entiendes
muy bien eso pero fíjate bien si no
tengo un medio un medio y lo multiplicó
por uno a esto lo multiplicó por uno
bueno pues un medio por uno pues es lo
mismo que un medio pero qué te parece si
me tomo un uno tramposo en lugar de
poner este uno de aquí voy a escribir
esto como un medio que multiplica am y
bueno qué le falta al 2 para llegar al 4
bueno le falta multiplicarse por dos
entonces qué te parece sí no
este uno este uno lo voy a tomar ahora
como dos medios como dos medios este uno
de aquí es lo mismo que dos medios y
porque me estoy tomando esto porque con
este uno tramposo o este uno fantasma
ahora sí sí yo recuerdo esto hace lo
mismo que dos entre cuatro dos cuartos y
multiplica éste por éste y éste por éste
y es justo lo que yo quería que un medio
fuera dos cuartos para que ahora si
pudiéramos sumar estas dos fracciones
teniendo en cuenta este denominador
común siempre que quiera sumar
fracciones necesitas un denominador
común así que vamos a ver otro ejemplo
yo sé que esto es bastante abstracto así
que intentemos ser un ejemplo más me voy
a tomar ahora
se me antoja un medio un medio
un tercio más un tercio y bueno lo
primero que quiero que te des cuenta es
que estas dos fracciones no tienen un
denominador común la primera tiene un 2
y la segunda tiene un 3 pero además hay
un problema más grande aquí si te das
cuenta no hay nada que le podamos ser al
2 multiplicarlo por ningún número que me
dé 3 ni tampoco en ningún número que
multiplicado por 3 me dé 2
bueno al menos no hay ningún número
natural entonces en este caso para no
complicarnos más la vida cuando queremos
buscar un denominador común lo que voy a
hacer es multiplicar estos dos
directamente dos por tres es 6 entonces
mi denominador común va a ser 6 mi
denominador común va a ser 6 en general
cuando tengas dos fracciones y estas
fracciones no tengan el denominador
común
vamos a usar siempre el mínimo común
múltiplo entre ellos dos y recuerda que
el mínimo común múltiplo entre dos
números por ejemplo aquí 2 y 3
es aquel múltiple o factor tanto de dos
como de tres es común pero que es el más
pequeño por ejemplo 18 también es un
múltiplo de 2 y de 3 pero 18 es un
número muy grande entonces para no
complicarnos la vida nos tomamos el más
pequeño y el más pequeño en este caso es
6 ese es el mínimo común múltiplo que en
este caso encontramos multiplicando dos
por tres
ok y ahora qué hacemos bueno pues ya
tenemos que este un medio lo voy a
escribir ahora con un denominador común
con 6 pero como puedo escribir en un
medio con un denominador común 6 bueno
pues la técnica es la siguiente voy a
dividir el 6 entre 2 y bueno como es un
múltiplo de 2 va a ser exacto 6 entre
dos es 3 y lo voy a multiplicar por este
número de acá arriba 3 por 13 es decir
que en este caso un medio es lo mismo
que 3 sextos y tiene toda la lógica del
mundo porque si yo tengo aquí un pastel
dividido en seis partes
mitad de seis partes de un pastel pues
son tres por lo tanto la mitad de un
pastel es lo mismo que tres partes de
seis que yo he dividido en pastel ok ya
esto qué te parece si le sumamos ahora
en un tercio provisto con el mismo
denominador con denominadores más 6
entonces voy a escribir este un tercio
como quien es bueno pues 6 entre 36
entre 3 2 2 por 1
ojo dicho de otra manera lo que estoy
haciendo es tomando un pastel
dividiéndolo en seis partes iguales y me
estoy dando cuenta que tomarme un tercio
de pastel es exactamente lo mismo que
tomarme dos sextos de ese pastel por lo
tanto un tercio es lo mismo que dos
sextos y ahora si ya tenemos un
denominador común nuestro denominador
común es 6 y ya sabemos qué hacer con
esto estás de acuerdo un medio es 3
sextos un tercio es dos sextos y como ya
tengo mi denominador común esto es lo
mismo que 6 y aquí arriba pongo 3 + 2
conservo el denominador en común y me
tomo la suma de los dos numeradores que
tengo y bueno pues esto es lo mismo que
cinco sextos ya está aquí está la suma
de un medio más un tercio un medio más
un tercio son cinco sextos aunque
parezca borrar es un poco bizarro pero
vamos a hacer otro ejemplo a ver si ya
cuando te queda un poco más claro ahora
quiero que te des cuenta que es lo mismo
para la resta si yo tengo por ejemplo
ya esto le quitó un tercio pues esto
sería exactamente lo mismo que y
entonces buscamos un denominador común
que en este caso ya sabemos que 6 ya
sabemos que 6 y un medio es lo mismo que
3 sextos esto lo habíamos concluido hace
rato entonces déjame ponerlo con este
color a 3 sextos menos un tercio
habíamos dicho que estos estos entonces
menos dos sextos y esto es lo mismo que
3 - 2 es 1 un 6º ok
así de fácil también es la resta o la
diferencia así que déjenme borrar el
pizarrón y dije te parece si hacemos un
par de ejemplos más a imagínate que yo
tengo un décimo
undécimo ya esto te quiero quitar uno
como puedo encontrar la diferencia entre
estas dos y bueno pues esa parece ser
que nos tracción pero qué te parece si
mejor escribimos el -1 o en este caso
este uno como fracción ahora qué
fracción nos va a convenir tomar este me
voy a quedar con un décimo ya esto le
voy a quitar y bueno no es lo mismo que
si buscamos un denominador común que te
parece si lo escribimos en decimos 1 es
lo mismo que 10 decimos porque recuerda
que 10 entre 10 me da 1 por lo tanto en
este caso 1 es exactamente lo mismo que
10 décimos undécimo menos 10 décimos y
cuántos esto bueno pues la respuesta de
esto está muy sencillo yo aquí tengo mi
denominador común que es 10 escribir
este uno en décimos para tener un
denominador común y 1 menos 10 esto es
lo mismo que menos nueve décimos si yo
tengo un peso pero debía diez pesos
realmente sigo teniendo
ok aquí hay otra diferencia de
fracciones y qué te parece si tomamos
ahora algo un poco más extraño lo voy a
tomar a menos un noveno ya esto le voy a
quitar además menos un cuarto y lo
primero que necesitamos es encontrar un
denominador común entre estos dos y para
no calcular el mínimo común múltiplo en
este vídeo el denominador común entre
estos dos es 36 9 por 4 es 36 y entonces
a este término voy a escribir en base 36
con un denominador de 36 ahora éste lo
voy a pasar aquí como algo que tengan
que ver con un denominador de 36 y
cuánto es un noveno menos noveno esto va
a ser negativo cuánto es menos un noveno
visto como denominador de 36
bueno pues al 9 lo multiplicamos por
cuatro para obtener 36 entonces si a
esta parte la multiplicamos por cuatro
la parte de arriba también la vamos a
tener que multiplicar por 4 4 por una es
ok ya esto le voy a quitar le voy a
quitar
y tengo el mismo problema con un cuarto
a un cuarto lo voy a transformar con el
denominador común 36 09 por 4 36 es
decir que a esta parte de abajo las 3
multiplicando por 9 si a esta parte de
abajo la estoy x 9 a esta parte de
arriba también la voy a multiplicar por
nueve entonces nos va a quedar nueve por
una es 9 y ya está tengo un denominador
común que es 36 y esto es lo mismo que
menos 4 menos 9 y cuantos esto esté un
cuarto lo transformamos aquí cuantos
esto bueno pues esto lo mismo que en 36
abajo y arriba me queda menos cuatro
menos nueve lo cual es menos 13 menos
304 pesos y después debo otros 9 pues en
total debo 13 pesos y ya está
esta es la respuesta de esta diferencia
de fracciones de esta resta de
fracciones ya se me acabó el tiempo por
este vídeo sin embargo voy a seguir
haciendo videos acerca de la suma y la
diferencia de fracciones para qué
no entiendas mucho mejor pero creo que
ya estás listo para el primer módulo de
suma y resta de fracciones que tenemos
en esta página hasta la próxima